bonjour un gars y au moins 42 ans je
suis administratives et je recherche
dans le secteur de secrétariat j'ai
obtenu mon bac professionnel
informations conseils orientation
j'ai poursuivi en bts négociation
clients tout faire dans le cadre de la
validation des acquis en 2006 j'habite à
saint denis je souhaite donc
dans l'idéal saint denis aux alentours
où jusqu'à saint paul à j'ai une ou
plusieurs compétences dont de 2007
jusqu'à 2014 en tant que secrétaire donc
en secrétariat polyvalence
j'ai eu l'opportunité d'avoir une
formation approfondie
dans tout ce qui est logiciels word
excel intranet internet
même en parallèle avoir une formation
dans les logiciels financiers tels que
j'ai ce projet astres je suis une
personne donc disponible sérieuse et
discrète mais surtout vagal
j'adore tout ce qui les relations
humaines j'adore faire des randonnées du
footing assez souvent et du yoga je suis
une personne dynamique
aimant la bonne humeur si mon profil
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à m'appeler